almost every interactive app sends
event-driven email on a per user basis
in today's video we'll look at the
fundamentals of transactional email
you've got mail we'll look at strategies
for sending email at the right time to
increase user engagement and of course
the technical implementation details
with firebase cloud functions and the
send grid transactional email API and
this is also the first video in a new
series called Minimum Viable Product
where we start with a generic spec or
requirement like how do I send email
from my app then build a full stack
solution with multiple front-end or
back-end approaches in this tutorial
you'll see the backend integration with
cloud functions but if you want to
extend it you can go to fire ship i/o
and see integrations for angular react
view svelte and flutter if you're new
here like and subscribe and leave a
comment below for a chance to win this
t-shirt now the great thing about
serverless functions is that they make
it really easy to implement secure
event-driven code today we'll write and
deploy four different cloud functions
each solving a specific problem the
first one will send a welcome email when
a new user signs up the second one is an
HTTP function that can be called
dynamically from your front-end code the
third one is a fire store function which
runs and responds to changes to the
database and the fourth function is
scheduled which allows you to send an
email at a specific time or date we'll
talk about these strategies in a little
more detail as we go along but let's get
started with the initial setup the first
thing you'll need is a send grid account
which is a paid service but it starts
off with a free tier to get you started
now you'll see a lot of different things
on the send grid dashboard but the thing
we're interested in is the transactional
templates page from this page you'll
want to create a new template and then
add a version to it
you can use your own custom HTML or you
can go to their drag-and-drop editor but
when it comes to dynamic transactional
email you'll basically want to create a
template that allows you to pass in a
bunch of data to customize it on a per
user basis and SendGrid uses handlebars
to achieve this in their templates
you'll notice over here on the left that
we have the subject wrapped in
handlebars that's because we'll be
dynamically passing the subject from our
back-end functions then in the email
body we have hello handlebars name which
will be passed and dynamically as well
and then also the text of the email
itself after you've created a template
make a note of the template ID we're
going to need that template ID as well
as our send grid API key do you get the
API key we go down here to set
and then we'll generate a new API key
that is restricted to the mail send API
because we don't really need anything
else for this demo from there you can go
into a blank project in your editor or
in my case I'm working from a mono repo
that has multiple front-end integrations
from the command line you can run fire
basinet functions and we'll be using
typescript but that part's optional
that's going to create a functions
directory and the root of the project so
we'll go ahead and CD into the functions
directory then run npm install SendGrid
slash mail and that gives us the
official node SDK for SendGrid
from there we need to tell the fire base
functions environment the SendGrid api
key and then also the template ID that
we'll use to send emails you don't have
to save the template ID here but it is
useful if you just want to swap it out
without having to completely redeploy
your functions so now that we can
securely access the API key we can go
into the source code in the index TS
file and initialize the send grid SDK
we'll also bring in firebase admin and
then make it reference to the firestore
database because one of our email
triggers will be on a database right
after importing SendGrid
the first thing you'll want to do is
reference your API key from the
environment as well as the template ID
if you saved it there then all you have
to do is call send grid set API key and
you're ready to start sending mail the
first type of transactional email that
we'll tackle is a welcome email this
strategy is really straightforward a new
user signs up for the app and you want
to send them an email with some account
details and some instructions on how to
get started with the app we can handle
this with the oncreate hook for firebase
off when a new user signs up this will
give us the user object which we can
then pass off to the send grid SDK to
send an email in the function body will
first format the message payload the to
property is the email address that we'll
be sending to and you can add multiple
email addresses here if you format it as
an array the next option is the from
email which in our case will always be
hello at fire ship il then we'll make a
reference to the template we created an
send grid based on its template ID then
we have a dynamic template data option
which will take any customized data that
we want to pass to send grid and this
data will be replaced wherever we used
handlebars in the template itself which
in our case is the subject line and also
the name in the email body and the final
step is to return a promise from the
function that sends the email
which we can do by simply returning the
SendGrid mail send with the message as
the argument and that's all it takes to
send a user a welcome email now that's
great for that specific use case but
there may be times when you just want to
send a regular HTTP call that validates
that the user is logged in and then send
an email to that user
and that's when callable HTTP functions
from firebase become very useful this
type of function would allow a user to
simply click a button and then we could
send some dynamic data to the backend
from our front-end code which could be
anything now you probably don't just
want any user to be able to do this you
want to make sure that it's a login user
that has a validated email when this
function is called will have the auth
context from the front-end so we can
check to make sure that that all context
is present and then it also has an email
address on the token before we send the
request to send grid now you'll notice
that the callable function also has a
data object in the payload this data can
be passed from the front-end again that
data can be anything you want from your
front-end code and again head over to
fire ship i/o to see how the actual
front-end integrations look in your
framework of choice now if you create a
callable function or just a regular HTTP
function you'll want to make sure that
the response you send back is
serializable to JSON that means you
don't just want to return the send grid
promise but instead of wait it and then
return an object that says success true
and then you could handle errors here if
anything goes wrong so that gives you a
really flexible way to manually send
email from your front-end but you may
want your functions to automatically
react to changes to your database for
example you might have a blog app and
the author of a blog might want to be
notified when a user comments on their
post and the database will have a
collection of posts and then will have a
sub collection of comments nested under
each post so this function will run
whenever a new comment is added to that
sub collection this function will
automatically give us access to the
Comet document but it won't give us
access to the post it will only give us
the post ID so what we need to do is
make a reference to that post in the
database and then we'll call get to
retrieve its actual data now if you're
in typescript strictmode you might also
want to say or an empty object just to
prevent errors from the typescript
compiler or you can set strict null
checks to false in your TS config but
now that we have the necessary data we
can then format the message we can use
all this dynamic data to create a custom
subject line and then we can also set
the
texts to something like this user said
something about this post and that gives
us a function that can send
transactional email based on changes to
the database and that tends to be a lot
more simple than trying to send requests
from your front-end code now at this
point we've only been sending email
based on user driven events but what if
we have something a little more static
like a weekly summary that we want to
send to each user
for that we can use a pub sub function
based on a schedule for example every
Friday at 0 500 from there we can make a
query to fire store for all the users
that are ready to receive the summary
that query is going to give us an array
of snapshots so we'll go ahead and map
those snapshots down to the actual email
on each document and that will just give
us an array of strings or email
addresses that we can send to send grid
from there you can use your own business
logic to calculate the weekly summary
and then we'll return a promise to send
the emails just like we've done and all
the other functions now in order to
start testing these functions out we
need to run firebase deploy only
functions and they'll be ready for use
in a front-end application you can test
the firestore or auth functions by
simply going into the firebase console
and creating new authentication records
or firestore documents in the
appropriate places and if you're ready
to integrate this with a front-end
framework head over to fire ship IO to
check out the full source code and the
framework specific videos I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there thanks
for watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]